we'll talk about one theorem that i
learned when i was in high school and a
seemingly miraculous method
to solve it which is my favorite thing
from the training for the international
math olympiad back in bulgaria the
theorem is called ptolemy's theorem and
the method will wait a few minutes
before we get there well let's start
with something that everyone knows what
is the theorem brady that you think
everyone knows
geometry pythagoras absolutely well what
do you know about it even i know this
one a squared plus b squared
is equal to c squared the old people
know this theorem but do they know how
to prove it
so ptolemy's theorem is somehow related
to this one
so who do you think is stronger ptolemy
or pythagoras stronger stronger they're
both greeks well pythagoras is more
famous that is true but they have to
compete with each other and we shall see
i need another
brown sheet already
yeah
so we're going to draw
a large circle we need four points on
this circle they form a so-called cyclic
quadrilateral it just means they lie on
a circle and you can also draw the
diagonals so what could ptolemy
tell us about these six segments it's
very beautiful it says
if you multiply the opposite sides and
add up those products you will get the
product of the two diagonals
so
a
b
times c d
plus a d
times b c
must be equal to the product of the two
diagonals ac times bt and this is what
ptolemy's theorem tells us
and it doesn't matter where those points
are on the circle
as long as they're in this order it's
going to work
so this is a property about points on a
circle now let's see
i said that pythagoras and ptolemies are
related
who's stronger
if i can prove pythagoras knowing
ptolemy's theorem then pthalamus is
stronger
okay so it would be like a a parent or a
yeah so ptolemy would be a parent of
pythagoras
is this possible certainly so if i draw
a right triangle and then take exactly
the same triangle and flip it over what
kind of a shape do you think brady i'm
going to get
a rectangle it is precisely a rectangle
so we have a b c d for the vertices now
a rectangle is a very symmetric figure
it has all right angles obviously so
its two diagonals also happen to be
equal then
moreover their intersection o is at
equal distances from each vertex
so they must be on a circle those points
exactly
but as soon as we have four points on a
circle guess what happens
ptolemy you say yes ptolemy would kick
in so now let us let us backtrack a
little bit we start it with the right
triangle
let us name it sides a
b and the diagonal will be c
okay but then this side should be a and
this side should be b and the other
diagonal should also be
c
let's hit this picture with ptolemis
so what do we have
the product of the opposite sides
a times a
plus the product of the other opposite
sides b times b must be equal to the
product of the two diagonals c times c
does this look like a theorem we've seen
before it looks good
that is precisely the pythagorean
theorem which means that ptolemy is
stronger pythagorean theorem is a
special case of ptolemy's theorem but
ptolemy's theorem can do a lot more
and so we create
a
new method today actually i've known
about this method for a long time
that will solve ptolemy's theorem so
actually ptolemis can be proven in many
different ways if you google you will
see lots of different proofs you will
see a proof in plain geometry which is
beautiful but very tricky to come up
with you can see technical proofs using
trigonometry who likes those or using
even complex numbers very sophisticated
but none of these approaches really
shows the true elegance and simplicity
of ptolemy's theorem none of them shows
you
why it is really true the new method
that we will talk about today called
inversion in the plane
looks originally like a mysterious black
box
because it will turn our circle in
ptolemy's situation into something that
the third grader can tackle
so it will turn this whole picture into
something very simple only three points
that are lined up a1
b1 and c1
what could a third grader tell me
about this picture what is true brady a
and b and then b and c makes a whole lot
correct if i add the two shorter ones i
must get the longer one look back at
ptolemy's theorem we are almost doing
something similar we're adding two
things and getting a third one
could
indeed this be the same situation but in
a different world in an inverted world
and the answer is yes
so what is inversion
inversion is obviously some
transformation of the plane at same
points some points to some other points
so let's think about other
transformations in the plane that we all
know so what would be one that you brady
have heard about like reflections and
things like that is that what we're
doing correct yeah you can reflect
across a line yeah that's that's a
perfectly good transformation how about
this one
that's called rotation about a point
definitely
about this one
that's called translation
and there is another one
when you click on a map to expand it to
zoom it out or zoom in
[Music]
that's what's called a rescaling or
dilation so suppose i draw an elephant
what do you think will the elephant look
after each of those transformations
would it look like a rabbit
or would it look like an elephant yeah
it will it will keep its elephant-ness
correct it may kind of flip-flop but it
will still look pretty much like an
elephant well our inversion is a
completely different animal
because we saw how it
transformates a circular picture into a
linear one so it must do something
horrible to shapes if you take your nice
elephant and hit it with that inversion
what will turn out in the end is
something that might look like aladdin's
shoe from the movie completely
ridiculous so we need to have control
over the situation what is going on so
for an inversion you need a circle into
the boss you can draw the circle
anywhere in the plane you like and as
big as you like and we mark its center
oh let's say we take a point outside of
this circle x where will this point go
it's like a small algorithm here we
start to the point x we connect it with
the center we draw a tangent through x
until it hits the circle at t
and then we drop a perpendicular to all
x so our point x
if it is outside of the circle
will travel into the circle into x1 this
actually can happen on any point in the
plane for instance if i take something
very close here and we just repeat we
connect it to all we draw a tangent and
we drop a perpendicular that will be
where y1 will go if i take any point
outside the circle where do you think it
will go it looks like it will go inside
the circle correct that can happen to
any point outside the circle now we have
more points to worry about what happens
if you start with a point inside the
circle
well we want to be consistent
so the logical thing is to reverse this
algorithm if i take a point z well i
still need the array through z and o
because everything important looks like
it's gonna lie there but then i have to
backtrack and erect a perpendicular at z
to this ray hitting the circle and
finally drawing my tangent to the circle
until it intersects our original array
in point z1 so if you start inside the
circle
you go outside of the circle that's what
inversion does to you
okay
i think we're still missing a few points
which points do they not talk about all
right the ones on the circle correct so
suppose i take a point how about u so u
is on the circle i'm going to treat it
as if it is a point outside of the
circle so we're going to apply our first
algorithm we connect it to o next if you
remember i'm supposed to draw a tangent
to the circle through that point okay
well the point is already on the circle
so it's just kind of kind of easy
and the tangent will intersect the
circle in our next point oh but that's
point u already
okay and next i have to drop a
perpendicular to my line until it
intersects that ray okay i'm gonna drop
a perpendicular to this line but i'm
already there so i literally have not
moved from you so any point on the
circle is going to go into itself and
that kind of makes sense
you will take outside of the plane this
infinite plane and you will squash it
inside you will take the inside you will
spray it outside spread it all over but
the points on the borderline are going
to stay fixed and not going to move
anywhere
what happens to the center
the center looks like it's an inside
point so we should apply our second
algorithm but can it possibly work
that center is a very strange point so
the first thing we have to do
by our second algorithm if you remember
point z
we need to connect it to the center well
how do we connect it to the center it's
already one point how do you draw that
ray yeah i i don't have a ray here so we
are already kind of stuck with our
algorithm but maybe you'll see it
doesn't matter which ray let's just draw
a random one okay there you go no
problem next i'm supposed to erect the
perpendicular certainly no problem i'm
supposed to draw a tangent to the circle
until
we are in trouble that's parallel
they're parallel
there is no way these two lines are
going to intersect so you may say oh it
goes somewhere
at infinity okay in that direction but
what happens if i chose a different
direction it's going to go in that
direction at infinity for our purposes
of proving ptolemy's theorem we don't
need to even bother with the center of
inversion
we will not define inversion at the
center when you're asking oh
that
that doesn't seem right it should be
defined everywhere
beg your pardon
if you for example
know anything about functions one of the
first function that would look like this
is f of x
equals to 1 over x brady can i plug in
any number here i think we're in trouble
zero there we can't put zero there so
this function is not defined at zero
but it's a perfectly good function and
you can see it all over the place
so why not leave inversion not defined
at the center now when i was in middle
school they used to tease us with the
following question how can you catch all
lions in africa
all right
well uh build the fans are really strong
fans around the circle
where would you like to stay brady
outside the circle or inside the circle
i want to be free on the outside uh-oh
that's where the lions are so you're
going to make sure that inside the
circle there are no lines i thought i
was a lion oh well okay all right i want
to be out i want to be away from the
lines okay so you stay inside this lion
free circle and then you hit the world
with inversion so all the lions are
outside they'll come in but you will be
safely outside and observing them well i
don't know if that's a worthy goal but
you see the excitement of fifth graders
how much they could foresee
the power of inversion what are the
basic properties of inversion we already
saw a few of them points outside the
circle go in points inside go out but do
they do this randomly what happens if i
apply inversion twice in a row
so point x from the outside is gonna go
into point x one on the inside but if i
do this once again i'll simply reverse
my algorithm and go back to x so what
happens is that points in the plane
are sort of merit
and they flip-flop from inside and
outside they have their chosen partner
and all they can do is flip-flop
the only points that the singleton are
those on the circle they stay put and o
we don't touch it we agreed so applying
inversion twice in a row will simply not
do anything to the plane it will keep
the points wherever they are this is
super important because if you take your
elephant
and invert it to aladdin's shoe what
would happen to a ladding shoe if you
hit it with inversion it will come back
and resurrect itself as the elephant
they need another sheet all right
you're going to ruin these bows
we saw that ptolemy's theorem was
originally situated on a circle but
miraculously that was turned into a line
now i want to know what happens to lines
in the plane but now some lines will be
more special than others some lines will
go through the center of inversion and
other lines will go not through the
center of inversion in different things
will happen to them in each case now let
us look at the first case where they go
through the center if i take a point
outside on this line it will go
inside this same line to its twin
exactly and they will flip-flop the
outside part of this line
will go inside and the inside is going
to go out and the points on the circle
we'll just stay put of course we said
we're not going to touch the center of
inversion so we don't care about it but
by and large they go to themselves
so they will still be lines exactly the
same lines you're not going to see any
difference before and after inversion so
if i took all the points on the line and
inverted them i would draw the same line
exactly well that's pretty nothing
happened to that line but if the line is
outside the circle
or inside but most importantly not going
through the center of the circle
something wild is going to happen let's
experiment so i'm going to take a point
x
on this line connect it to the center
draw a tangent drop a perpendicular all
right well so far no surprises i knew
that x was going to go inside the circle
but let's experiment more now i'm going
to take another point why
draw a tangent and drop a perpendicular
this is y1 so far i don't see any
surprise do you think this line is going
to go into a line here
could it possibly go into a line
i don't think so
because
there is no line inside the circle it's
going to be just a line segment at best
but is it a line segment let us
experiment we have z draw a tangent and
draw a perpendicular oh we already see
that the points
inside the circle are not anymore lying
on a line on what shape do you think
really they lie i reckon i can guess now
yeah i guess
well
i reckon we're going to get a circle yes
but what kind of a circle
circles are of two types
they either pass through the center of
inversion or they don't what is your
guess will our circle pass through o or
will it not
i think it
oh i don't know
because you told me o doesn't map to
anything so oh actually it matters a lot
we just don't touch it
it's like the king who does not
participate in the battle but only
oversees what's happening okay now
i can draw maybe one more point but
let's try to draw it far away
from all okay
maybe that will give us a clue yeah what
happens to points that are far away from
o where do they go and the inversion
close to o
or far away from o now remember those
lines in africa the further away the
lines are from our fans the closer to
something they will go i am getting
close to all closer and closer and
closer and you can go infinitely far
away
and you're going to get infinitely
close to all
so actually if you
continue doing this you will clearly see
a shape of a circle now of course my
picture is drawn by hand so it looks
more like an ellipse but definitely
you can see that that's not a line so it
is a theorem that
a line that does not go through the
center
will map to a circle that goes through
the center okay
and that is fundamental now
it looks like we still need a lot of
ground to cover but do we now how many
circles are there with respect to
inversion
two
they either pass through the center of
inversion or they don't
but i already have one that passes it's
right here
what do you think brady happens if i hit
that circle with inversion
you you get your line back exactly
absolutely because
doing inversion twice is gonna get us
back where we started let us summarize
so far lines through the center go to
themselves lines not through the center
go to circles through the center and
conversely circles through the center go
to lines not through the center are we
missing one type of figure here
we think we are
and this is
circles that don't go through the center
of inversion a circle not through the
center of inversion
goes to another circle
not through the center of inversion and
in fact that's a theorem and it can be
proven using pairs of similar triangles
just like any of the other theorems in
this stock we know properties of
inversion now we're back to ptolemy's
theorem
let's see if we can prove it at our
first attempt
so what i have here is our
cyclic quadrilateral in other words four
points on a circle and we are trying to
prove something about the size and the
diagonals as ptolemy's theorem says we
want to simplify this picture how can we
simplify obviously lines are preferable
to circles they are simpler to work with
can i turn
this circle
into a line
yes with inversion but i need to choose
my center of inversion
very carefully
because different circles will go to
different figures
if you remember if a circle doesn't pass
through the center of inversion it's
just going to go to another circle that
doesn't pass through the center of
inversion and that's no use to us
however
if a circle passes through the center of
inversion it's gonna miraculously turn
into a line not through the center of
inversion
so where should the center of inversion
be if i want to make a line out of this
circle what do you think brady wow
you've got infinite options
yes but there is one place where it must
be it must be somewhere
on the original circle for ptolemy so
that the original circle passes through
the center of inversion yeah all right
so let me just take something symmetric
here looks oh excellent now you are
thinking i should draw the circle of
inversion i don't have to actually all i
care is about the shapes of figures
after inversion not exactly where they
are located
so at any rate
this circle through the center of
inversion will turn into a line not
through the center so i can just be bold
and
draw a line
not through the center of inversion and
declare that my circle goes there why
not now we want to quickly figure out
where do the points a d c and b go you
may be thinking well now i need the
circle of inversion in order to do all
of these tangents and all of these
perpendiculars
no we can be efficient we can apply a
little bit of logic
for instance take point b
i know that point b has to go somewhere
on this line because it is on our blue
circle
okay so it has to be somewhere but also
i know that it lies on re or b because
that was
our first step of the algorithm
for inversion
so it has to lie both on this ray and on
our line l
so i think we figured out it's here and
the same way we can efficiently find the
images of the other points so our cyclic
quadrilateral now gets flattened onto a
line and i do want to give a warning
here i'm not saying that the sides of
the quadrilateral become
line segments no they will actually
become arcs of circles most likely
i am saying that the vertices are now
lined up on the line do you think that's
really the best we can do with inversion
because
a while ago
i promise that inversion will make this
picture
look
something that the third grader can cope
with three points on a line and then we
are adding up the two shorter segments
to get the bigger one well i mean you've
got four so you could you could do
ah that's not for a third grader
now there are too many segments floating
about here okay we really want
simplicity and elegance okay
so we have to go back again to our
choice for the center of inversion even
though we are on the right track to
choose it on the original ptolemy's
circle
we were just a little bit too sloppy
where exactly to place it if i want to
eliminate one of those points where
should all be on one of the points
exactly because we're not going to even
touch it we're going to leave it there
and forget about it as our center of
inversion
so since we promised we're going to end
up with points a1 b1c1 which point shall
we lose well
g that's right that is exactly
where we want to place our center of
inversion
now we have to cut and i have to draw
another picture because i cannot just do
completely it's too messy
our first attempt failed but we don't
give up the blue circle is now going to
go into a line l
but we have only three points to map
points b
c
and a so we've got a1
b1
and c1
okay great
so that was what inversion promised us
we can get it
to this simplified situation
and we do know that if i add the length
segments the two shorter ones
i'm going to get the longer one a1 b1
plus b1 c1 is a1c1
so what did we talk about what happens
to distances on the inversion
no we didn't
but i actually need exactly to know what
happens
to the all distances
here i have six of them that participate
in ptolemy's theorem
in terms of the new distances like how
have they scaled exactly
and we know that uh inversion is not
like
dilation or rescaling of the plane he
does actually quite horrible things two
points for example if you have two
points that are very close to the center
of inversion
each of them is going to be mapped very
very far away
and that will enlarge the segment
drastically
so we need to derive a couple of
formulas that will tell us exactly what
happens to distances on the inversion so
let's get started this is
the circle of inversion a point x
outside the circle there is something
that we have overlocked here
there is a segment that is missing which
one it is segment ot
that is
super important
first of all it's r long that's the
radius of inversion
but there is another right angle every
time you draw a tangent it is
perpendicular to the radius so now when
you look at this picture you see a bunch
of similar triangles there are three
triangles in this picture two small and
one large and they are all similar
because they have the same angles i'm
interested only in two of them in this
small red one and in the large one so
let's see what they will give us
triangle o
t
x one is similar
to triangle o
x
t and you can check that the right
angles are matching so what do i need
from this i need the ratio of segments o
t
2 o x
1 is equal to ox to ot all right big
deal but you know what ot is the same
and it's the radius
so i can simplify this
to
multiplying the two distances from the
center o x and o x one
to the radius squared which is o t
squared and this is our first distance
formula in other words all the distance
from the center times new distance from
the center is always fixed it is r
squared which actually explains the
phenomena why points close to the center
are going to be mapped very very far
away
because those two distances all the new
have to balance each other to multiply
to r squared so if one of them is small
the other one has to be large and vice
versa okay that's formula one now we
need formula two ah
right here so what we have here
is another inversion
we really need to know what happens to
any segment on the inversion not just to
segments
that contain the center
because we found formulas for those but
not to random other segments so what we
have here is point a that goes to a1 and
b goes to b1 if you wonder where the
circle of inversion is it's somewhere
like this in between them but who cares
about that we don't need it now again we
see two triangles here
do you think they're similar the answer
is yes first of all they share a common
angle that's good news and now what do
we know about
these distances from the center we just
had a formula if i multiply oa1
that will be the same as ob or b1 but
that turns into a ratio o a to ob
is equal to
ob1
one
uh-huh
obi-wan kenobi right
what we have here is a ratio of
sides
plus an angle makes two similar
triangles and we can now reap the
effects of this similarity we can more
rip off the effects can can i say that
rip off no not the lip reap
when you are you're gathering the
harvest we can okay i'll reap the
effects i'll get you yep
we can read the effects of this
similarity
first of all what are the two triangles
we are talking about we have triangle o
a1b one is similar to triangle o
but it's not going to be a it's going to
be b because the points flip-flop in
this ratio okay so now what i'm
interested in
only
is the new distance between the points
in terms of the old one so let's use
some ratios a1 b1 over oa1 is equal to
a b
over
ob all right that looks like a mess but
we're gonna resolve it we're interested
in the new distance a1 b1 so we solve
for it we push oa1 to the other side we
get a b
times all a1 over ob now this is a
complete mishmash of new and old
distances i have new distance a1 b1 here
i have all distances i don't like this
one this is new i want my new distance
to be completely expressed in something
that happened before inversion so i have
control over it can i replace o a1 the
answer is yes
because we had our first formula that if
i multiply
the distances to the center of inversion
this is always r squared so from here
all a1 will be some ratio of the radius
and all a
and we can simply plug it in
and
get oh this looks like a messy messy
formula but we really need to understand
what it says all right so it says new
distance
is equal to
its predecessor
the old distance times always r squared
over the old distances to the center so
everything is expressed in terms of the
world before inversion
we are ready to finally prove ptolemy's
theorem thank the lord
okay
brady you have to be excited how all of
this messy stuff actually proves it i
know you're excited but you're not the
one who has to edit the video afterwards
i know
okay final attempt
we are proving ptolemy's theorem yeah
but we will apply our distance formula
three times in the inverted world
inverted world means really this red
line here where everything mapped on the
inversion
so we would have
a 1 b1 plus b1 c1 is a1c1 now these are
new distances so we can rewrite them in
terms of our formula so new distances
were the old distance times the radius
squared over the all distances to the
center but the center is not all really
it's d
so we will be talking about distances
from a and b
to the center which is d in other words
a g
times b g that alone is a1b1 and we
continue in a similar fashion
we have all distance bc
times radius squared and then distances
to the center which is
d and finally ac
times r squared over distances to the
center
hmm
brady
what would you like to do when things
repeat
get rid of them that's right so what do
i get rid of them you must be able to
get rid of those r squareds correct we
divide everything inside by r squared
and we miraculously understand that the
radius of inversion did not matter here
we just got rid of it
okay next who likes denominators can we
get rid of them too the answer is yes we
just have to find the common denominator
of those three fractions
now they
share a few things they have a d twice
and c d twice and b d twice so we will
multiply everything
by a d times bd times cd that's the
common denominator now if i multiply
this fraction by
this product we will in essence cancel
the whole denominator and the only thing
that will be left to multiply is cd so
that cd must be multiplied by a b so we
end up with a b times c d full stop does
this remind us of something a d times c
d we have just multiplied the opposite
sides of our cyclic quadrilateral this
looks promising
let's see if the rest will match
bc from the numerator what's missing
here
i think only a d is missing
a d
b c times a d opposite sides
and that is equal to
a c one of our diagonals times
what's left
bd
the other diagonal
we are done
we have just shown ptolemy's theorem
was that easy
well
it wasn't an easy proof in the sense of
the ideas that were used because
inversion is definitely not easy and it
is not a natural thing that one would
just try um on the spur of the moment
but the actual computations and the
proofs really boil down to similar
triangles
and operations with fractions as well as
realizing
where to take our center of inversion
that was the key point
it was worth the wait
now you ask um is there anything else
useful that ptolemy's theorem can prove
the answer is yes
not only the pythagorean theorem follows
from ptolemy's theorem but a couple of
really cool facts
let's look at them
no and i thought we were finished
well we've come this far why not watch
the additional footage showing how
ptolemy's theorem reveals a link between
pentagons and the golden ratio i don't
think so
one of those roots is utterly impossible
we've also got a little bit of extra
footage about inversion in fact this
kind of property is used very often in
solving problems with inversion
thank you for bringing it up and if
that's not enough you can go back and
watch numberphile's classic video about
epic circles links are in all the usual
places on screen down in the video
description